If you need any indication of the direction
movies are going in this fall, well, Lego
Batman said it best: Darkness, no parents.
From a Girl with the Dragon Tattoo sequel
to a long-awaited first look at The Conjuring's
spinoff-slash-prequel The Nun, June is promising
a Halloween season that'll have you cowering
under the covers.
That said, it's not all doom and gloom on
the docket.
June also brought us trailers for Ralph Breaks
the Internet, the Peter Jackson-produced Mortal
Engines, and the Transformers spinoff Bumblebee,
to name a few.
In fact, we're looking at incredible trailers
for movies as far out as 2019, which means
there are a lot to run through.
Here are all the trailers from June 2018 for
movies that are sure to blow you away.
Siberia
Keanu Reeves is front and center in the first
trailer for Siberia, a crime thriller about
a sketchy diamond smuggler who heads to Russia
to look for his missing partner.
There, he discovers that his partner was trying
to cheat some terrifyingly serious Russian
mobsters.
Will he be able to make it out of Siberia
in one piece, or will he find himself on the
wrong side of Russian justice?
Find out when Siberia lands in theaters on
July 13th.
Poor Boy
To be honest, Poor Boy doesn't look like an
instant classic.
The story of two hustling brothers who concoct
a scheme to finally get out of their nowhere
town, the film hit a few festivals in 2016
and then disappeared until it secured a 2018
release date.
The highlight of the trailer has to be Michael
Shannon in rodeo clown makeup delivering slow,
existential quotes while he takes long drags
on his cigarette.
Hopefully that won't be the only reason to
see Poor Boy.
But even if it is, well, there are worse ways
to spend an afternoon.
Look for it on July 13th.
Robin Williams: Come Inside My Mind
What can you say about Robin Williams that
hasn't been said before?
"I do a great impression of a hot dog"
He entertained decades of fans, and now, HBO
is releasing a documentary about Williams'
life to twist the faucet on those tear ducts
one more time.
With a wealth of behind-the-scenes footage,
photographs from his childhood, and interviews
with Williams' friends and family, Robin Williams:
Come Inside My Mind looks like an intimate
glimpse into the life of the legendary comic.
"There you are, you've become a reformed alcoholic,
you've got a steaming glass of Perrier going,
'I feel so much better about myself!'"
Take a look when it premieres on HBO on July
16th.
Alpha
The story of a dog and his prehistoric boy,
Alpha is having no trouble tugging at viewers'
heartstrings with its trailers.
Full of sweeping music and touching moments,
Alpha's trailers bill it as a movie about
the domestication of dogs.
Think of it as the gritty origin story of
your mom's Corgi.
And okay, that may not seem like gripping
cinema at first glance, but Alpha might just
pull it off through spectacle alone.
The trailers reveal rich cinematography filled
with gorgeous landscapes and soaring aerial
shots.
Throw in a story about a sad wolf, and you've
got your hands on cinematic gold.
Look for Alpha on August 17th.
The Little Stranger
With 2015's Room, director Lenny Abrahamson
made a unique, gut wrenching movie about a
mother who would go to any lengths to protect
her son.
The first trailer for his upcoming The Little
Stranger reveals another subtle, nerve-jarring
ride, this time with a supernatural twist.
The story centers on a small-town doctor,
played by Domhnall Gleeson, who's called out
to an old estate to fix up a sick maid.
It isn't long before the old house begins
revealing disturbing secrets, suggesting a
supernatural presence.
The Little Stranger is based on the 2009 gothic
novel of the same name, and arrives in theaters
on August 31st.
The Nun
The creepy, evil nun Valak made her first
appearance in The Conjuring 2, and The Nun
will serve as something of an origin story
for the demon, with the main story centered
on a Romanian priest and a young nun who are
investigating what happened to a nun in an
old church.
It looks like a delightfully eerie popcorn
movie to check out this fall.
The Nun hits theaters on September 7th.
Mandy
Here's what we figured out from the trailer
for Mandy: If losing your mind was a color,
it'd be Nic Cage in neon pink with a homemade
battle axe.
"So what you huntin'?"
"Crazy evil!"
The story of a man and a girl living in the
woods who get targeted by a sadistic biker
cult, Mandy is somewhere between an acid trip
and a horror movie, the perfect platform for
Nic Cage to let loose with whatever it is
that Nic Cage lets loose with.
Take a look when Mandy barrels into theaters
on September 14th.
The Old Man and the Gun
Robert Redford headlines this upcoming crime
film as an old man who knocks over banks by
flashing a gun and a smile.
The Old Man and the Gun is based on the real
life of Forrest Tucker, a career criminal
who escaped from prison nearly 20 times.
The events of the film follow Tucker as an
elderly man who's still pulling heists, enchanting
the bank workers with his gentlemanly smile
even as he makes off with thousands in cash.
"He had a gun."
"You saw it?"
"Well, he was also sort of a gentleman."
Robert Redford is perfectly cast to play a
suave, elderly criminal.
And with Casey Affleck, Sissy Spacek, and
Danny Glover co-starring, The Old Man and
the Gun looks like a guaranteed winner.
Look for it on September 28th.
Bad Times at the El Royale
When seven strangers show up at a seedy hotel
near Lake Tahoe, the meeting kicks off a fateful
night where nothing is what it seems.
As the hours in the hotel wear on, each of
them reveals a dark secret.
"I'm not really a priest."
"Yeah, no s---."
Written and directed by Drew Goddard, who
also helmed the genre-twisting Cabin in the
Woods, Bad Times at the El Royale is a tour
de force of star power.
Jeff Bridges, Chris Hemsworth, Dakota Johnson,
and Jon Hamm headline the film, and the brief
trailer hits all the right beats without giving
away any plot twists.
Check in to the El Royale when the movie lands
in theaters on October 12th.
First Man
Directed by the Oscar-winning director of
La La Land, First Man centers on a young Neil
Armstrong during the lead-up to the Apollo
11 mission to land on the moon.
Of course, it's safe to say that we know how
the story will end, but the dramatized version
of the momentous event coupled with Ryan Gosling's
portrayal of Armstrong should be enough to
keep audiences on the edge of their seats.
Look for First Man to land on October 12th.
Serenity
Matthew McConaughey stars in this upcoming
thriller as a quiet fishing boat captain who
gets an unexpected visit from his ex-wife,
played by Anne Hathaway.
She has a simple request: Take her current
husband out on the water and leave him for
the sharks.
After that, the trailer grinds into gear,
throwing out tantalizing glimpses of the story
while the slow tick of a fishing reel drives
up the tension.
If the movie is anywhere near as good as the
trailer, Serenity looks like a sure win to
look forward to later this year.
Check it out when it reaches theaters on October
19th.
Ralph Breaks the Internet
The story of an arcade villain who decides
that he wants to become a hero, 2012's Wreck-It
Ralph is both an awesome love letter to video
games and a heartfelt adventure tale.
"And where you coming from?"
"Ahhh, Pac-Man!"
"You bring any fruit with ya?"
"No, no fruit!"
"Okay then."
If the trailer for the sequel is any indication,
it's heading in the same direction.
After a worryingly Emoji Movie-esque opening
that sees Ralph and Vanellope travel to the
internet and gaze out over a sprawling city
of product placement, the trailer finds its
stride.
Vanellope ends up in a room full of Disney
princesses, they escape from stormtroopers,
and it all looks like a lot of fun.
Check out Ralph Breaks the Internet on November
21st.
"Shouldn't it be Ralph Wrecks the Internet?"
"Yes, since he is Wreck It Ralph?"
"Uh yeah, but, break the internet?
It's like, a thing."
The Girl in the Spider's Web
Sony seems to have a plan for their adaptations
of the Millennium book series, even if nobody
else can figure it out.
Trailing David Fincher's 2011 The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo and a complete, critically
acclaimed trilogy of Swedish film adaptations,
Sony is replacing the entire cast and moving
straight to the fourth novel, The Girl in
the Spider's Web.
To be fair though, this new take looks like
it's in good hands.
Don't Breathe's Fede Alvarez is directing,
with Golden Globe winner Claire Foy stepping
in as hacker vigilante Lisbeth Salander.
Look for it in theaters on November 9th.
Creed II
Michael B. Jordan is returning to the ring
this year in Creed II.
The trailer sees Creed training harder than
ever while balancing his family life.
It all ends with a tantalizing glimpse of
Ivan Drago's son, promising an epic, emotional
fight.
The first Creed film became a surprise hit
when it was released in 2015, resulting in
an Oscar nomination for Best Supporting Actor
for Sylvester Stallone and a major box office
take.
Creed II looks like it's following in the
same footsteps.
Look for it on November 21st.
Welcome to Marwen
Steve Carell stars in Welcome to Marwen as
Mark Hogancamp, an artist who lost his ability
to draw after he was beaten by neo-Nazis.
Through extensive, detailed miniature models,
Mark channels his imagination into a new form
of art: dolls.
"Now I am making your silver pants blue."
And sometimes, his imagination takes him straight
into the stories of the dolls themselves.
Welcome to Marwen looks like one of the most
unique movies to hit theaters in 2018.
Take a look when it premieres on November
21st.
Mortal Engines
The Oscar-winning screenwriting team behind
The Lord of the Rings is taking on another
epic adaptation this December with Mortal
Engines, a post-apocalyptic tale about wheeled
cities that rove around the land preying on
weaker cities.
The story centers on a young woman named Hester
Shaw, who becomes a fugitive from the rolling
city of London after she attempts to assassinate
a powerful man named Valentine.
The trailer sets up the premise beautifully
while leaving the main meat of the story for
the movie itself.
Look for Mortal Engines on December 14th.
Bumblebee
Eleven years and five movies after kids first
fell in love with HD robot toys, the Transformers
franchise is getting back to its roots.
Bumblebee sees the magical beginnings of the
yellow car alien known as, well, Bumblebee,
back when he was just a humble VW Bug in a
dusty scrapyard.
Hailee Steinfeld stars as the human girl who
discovers him, kicking off a new adventure
that sees the unlikely duo on the run from
the evil government and eviler robots.
Sort of like the first movie, if all the people
were replaced with different people.
Take a look when Bumblebee transforms and
rolls into theaters in December 2018.
The LEGO Movie 2: The Second Part
Bricksburg is in dire straits in the first
trailer for The LEGO Movie 2, which sees the
town of LEGO people transformed into a post-apocalyptic
wasteland.
But desolate ruins and sewer babies aren't
enough to get Emmet down.
He's still the cheerful, naive guy he always
was, Master Builder or not.
The LEGO Movie 2: The Second Part is scheduled
to hit theaters in February 2019.
Dumbo
Continuing their ongoing march of live-action
remakes, Disney released their first trailer
for Dumbo this June.
The journey of a little circus elephant who
gets picked on until he learns how to fly,
it's definitely a story that's been enchanting
kids for generations.
The new trailer doesn't go into much of the
story, instead focusing on the essence of
the tale, which is nothing short of pure childhood
magic.
Look for it in theaters in March 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!